There I was being a regular kid until I was nine.
And one weekend, we went to the Hayden Planetarium right here in New York City.
And right, it's just another museum...
...until they turn out the lights and the stars come out.
Back then, space shows were live and so there's this voice,...
..."We are now in the universe and here are the stars."
You're looking up, you don't see anybody, you just hear this voice...
...so it's like, "The universe is talking to me."
And there was a sky unlike that which I've ever seen,...
...having been born and raised in New York.
And there you are, immersed, bathed in the cosmos.
And that can be quite influential on a nine-year-old, as it was on me.